Well, come to talks at Google in
Cambridge, Massachusetts. Today.
It's my enormous pleasure to
welcome I William Pollack,
author of the recently published book,
the only woman in the room,
why science is still a boy's club.
Mrs Pollock is professor of creative
writing at the University of Michigan.
She is a published author of novels,
nonfiction and textbooks,
but she was not always as
we see her now at one time,
she overcame many obstacles,
most of them external.
A few, uh, if I read the book correctly,
internal probably to become one of the
first two women at Yale University to
earn a Bachelor of
Science degree in physics.
She graduated summa cum laude with
honors and yet chose at that time not to
pursue a career in physics,
which you had dreamed of her entire life,
but rather to pursue a career in writing.
Part of this book is a memoir that
explains how she got to that point.
What she did after that,
it picks up again as a research
study sparked by Larry Summers.
Infamous comment or
famous comment and 2005 g,
why aren't there more women
teaching and the hard sciences?
Could this be because et cetera.
Uh,
so she took it on herself to interview
former fellow students and teachers and
women who had since made careers in
stem subjects to find out the answer.
I won't spoil it here. Um, there
may not be a happy ending yet,
but perhaps it's something
we can work toward.
Please join me in
welcoming Eileen Pollock.
Hi everybody. Can you all hear
me back? Roads and everything?
Thanks for coming out. I can only
imagine how busy you all are. And, uh,
it's really,
uh,
an honor and it's exciting for
me to be in a Google space.
I've, you know, we all the outsiders here,
how mystical it is for you guys.
And it turns out it's true.
I've just never worked in such a place.
Um,
but I have a lot of attachments to
Kendall Square. So back in the 80s,
my ex husband was doing his mdphd at
Harvard and MIT and his lab was right on
the other side of Ames street. But of
course, none of this looked like this.
It was just this huge wasteland because
they were supposed to build the Kennedy
Space Center here.
So they destroyed all the buildings
and then Kennedy was assassinated.
So it became the Johnson
Space Center in Houston.
And for all those many years,
there was just this big,
vast nothing here.
I'm,
the only place to eat was there was the
old bnb deli. It's not, it's still here.
Anyway. Um, so it's, it's
interesting for me to be back and I,
my first job was at MIT.
I,
I worked for the head of the
civil engineering department, um,
that he would get assigned from the UN
to write books about how to build low
cost housing in third world
in developing countries.
And I researched and wrote them for him.
And considering I had never even built
a birdhouse and had never been to a
developing country.
I have always hoped that really nobody
ever use those books at the UN for
anything.
So what I thought I would do was talk
a little bit more about the book, um,
because my publisher
would want me to do that.
And I do hope you'll be to get a copy
and I would love to sign them for you
afterward.
And then what I'm actually gonna read
to you from though is a more recent
article that's more directly, um,
focused on, on tech and how, um,
some of the issues affect
a place like maybe Google.
Um, so yeah, so the book is divided into
a bunch of parts and it starts with,
with sort of an investigative memoir.
Um,
when Larry Summers made his
remarks, uh, you know, I got upset,
but I had actually known Larry for years.
We went way back.
I was a debater in high school.
I was just nerdy in every way.
You could be nerdy. And Larry was older
as he, he judged our team and then I,
you know, kept track of him later
and, and, and knew him. But, um,
so I got all upset that he would have
thought that there was even a possibility
that one reason there weren't more
women physics professors at Harvard was
because of any kind of innate aptitude
problems or that women didn't want to
work hard as hard as men.
The other reasons he gave seem to be
more on target that they were cultural
reasons is and bias and things like that.
So I actually sat down to write him an
email to explain why I had really not
gone on in physics, even though I so
passionately wanted to in the email,
just went on and on and I ended up with
this like 20 page email and instead of
sending it to him,
then I decided to write a book.
And then I sent the book to him after
it was done and he was good enough to,
there's a blurb on the
back and he said, oh, now,
now I see the light and I understand
what I didn't understand before.
So that made me feel good.
Um,
but I realized that I didn't even
really understand why I hadn't gone on.
It was so painful for
me to have walked away,
to have worked so incredibly hard
to get that physics degree and do,
do this research and stuff that I,
when I walked away from it,
I really didn't want to ever think about
the part of my life that had wanted to
be a physicist.
Um,
and so then I had to go back and
really revisit everything and you know,
part of it was, um, as Jonathan
said, sort of these external factors.
So I went to a not very good rural
high school and I actually wasn't,
we didn't have any AP courses,
but there was a sort of accelerated track
that a couple of boys got to take in
science and math. And I wasn't allowed
to do it because as the principal said,
girls don't go on in
science and math anyway.
So you would just be wasting a seed and
besides it would ruin your social life.
I didn't have a social life because
if you're a girl at that age and your
interest really good at science and
math, that does help anyway. But, um,
so I got very bored and angry and I stayed
home and taught myself what I thought
were,
I was really reading about physics,
but I thought I was actually studying
physics and I taught myself calculus.
But when I got to Yale, I was just
blown out of the water, right?
Because first of all,
there were 118 guys and two women.
Um, and they, almost all of them had, had,
had gone to really good schools and
had two years of high school physics,
two years of advanced calculus. And I
had taught myself this stuff from books.
So I flunked my first midterm
and I was going to drop,
which is what happens to many young
women in minorities. You get there,
realize that you have had a terrible
background, you flunk your first test.
And of course those courses, or
even cold weed out courses, right?
So there's this ethos that if you get
there and you're not already like top of
the pack, you couldn't possibly
be good, are worth saving.
And so let's weed you out.
Luckily I had, you know,
the book is not a story
about villains. Um, uh,
I know that the 70s sound
like a really long time ago.
You're mostly really young,
but it was actually didn't feel much
different from now in terms of sort of
feminism and sexism. And we, we already,
we felt even then that all the
battles have been fought and, um,
that women could do anything. And I didn't
feel like a pioneer. And I had really,
really nice. I had all male professors,
there were no women professors,
but I had really, really nice guys
teaching me math and physics. Um,
but, and so when I was
going to drop, actually my,
it was very unusual,
but my freshman year of physics professor
wouldn't let me drop the course.
And he gave me very good advice and I
stuck it out and I worked incredibly hard.
Um, and as often happens, if you come from
behind, you overshoot the mark. Right?
And by the time I was a senior,
I was top of my class and I had
done all this research. And, um,
and so the fact that I didn't go
and I had almost perfect grades,
but I didn't think that I was good
enough because no one said you're good at
this, right? No one said, are you
going to Grad School? You know,
and I thought if I were good,
someone would have said go on.
Which is a big difference between
most young women in most guys,
that guys are raised more to,
you know, make their own value.
Like not look to other people to pat you
on the bed, you know, head and say, yes,
you're, you're pretty your queue,
you can do it, whatever. Um, and,
and to women more need this
encouragement from the outside to go on.
I didn't have confidence because I had
come from behind and I still thought of
myself as behind.
If you're the only woman in the room,
the only black person in the room, the
only whatever in the room, there's this,
it's called a stereotype effect.
But this self consciousness where
everything you do you feel like you're
representing your whole
gender or your whole race, um,
you feel self conscious every time.
I would cross my legs in class,
even though I was wearing jeans.
So like the professor would stop talking.
You know what?
It was so distracting.
So there were just so many distractions
and I was so isolated. Really.
None of the,
all the guys did their problem sets
together and I was off just working all by
myself. Nobody ever even
talked to me in classes. Um,
and so those were the factors that
I started to realize had really been
debilitating. Um, and the reasons,
the main reasons that I didn't go on.
Um,
so when I, the second
part of the book was, um,
I wanted to see whether my
experience had been unique,
whether anybody had ever
felt anything similar. Um,
and I was really interested in how
it compared to young women today.
I assumed that, um, that
things really must've changed.
And so I was shocked, uh, when I,
so I went back to Yale to talk
to the young women there. Um,
I followed up with people
I had been in school with,
but I was really interested in,
in young women today and young women at
University of Michigan where I teach so
I could compare a public
school to, you know, an ivy.
And I was really shocked. Um, there were
a few more young women in the classes,
but most of them seem to be
saying that inside itself,
the same as I had felt right,
that they weren't getting encouragement,
they didn't have the confidence,
they felt isolated,
but also, and what I think this is,
it was very hard for me to admit it.
And then I think for them
to admit it to me too,
they felt that these beautiful,
smart,
charming young women at
Yale or saying to me,
nobody wants to date us because they,
when we say we're a physics major,
that's the end. Um, is anybody going
to marry me? You know? And I was like,
can I really be hearing this
at Yale in, in, you know,
2012 it just couldn't be.
And then they started telling
me stories of the teasing.
They had been getting like in junior
high and high school, um, you know, oh,
I'm going to grade you on the girl curve
and your physics class and the boys
will be graded on the boy curve.
I mean, this me from my childhood,
this is like from people
your age, um, or uh,
one friend's daughter
was told by her teacher,
you're too pretty to be good at
math. Um, and very recently I heard,
so I heard from one young woman who,
um,
uh, walked into, she wanted
to be in the robotics club.
She walked in and it was all guys, she
turned around and walked out. But um,
three young women who are on a robotics
club in high school and they were
preparing for a competition.
The club was going to host a competition
and the advisor for the robotics club
said to the three young women, you can
be in charge of RefreshMints right.
Show they, they just dropped the
club. They never told him like,
you shouldn't say that. Um, so this
stuff was still going on and that, um,
that really shocked me.
Um,
so I think what's different is there a
few more women, they last a bit longer.
Um,
there,
there are a few more organizations
for support groups and things, but,
um, I was really surprised
how little had had changed.
Um, for the third part of the book, um,
I did look at the studies that had been
done on gender bias in the science and
more and more of those studies are
being done now partly because of Larry
Summers remarks.
So again,
I think he inadvertently
did a real service because
a lot of people got mad and
said, all right, he wants us to give him
the reasons for this, let's figure it out.
And um,
and some of those studies are being,
are very recent and are
really very powerful.
So the one I quoted in the excerpt that
appeared in the Times magazine two years
ago, it's in the book by Joe Handlesman
at Yale, which really shocked me.
So it's about implicit bias.
Um,
she ran the study at mostly
research institutions,
but one of the categories was engineering.
So it was engineering, physics,
chemistry,
I think math was the other one.
And what they did was just mock up,
um,
job applications for an
entry level position.
So it's sorta for someone who's between
Undergrad and thinking of it one day
going on for a phd and in the meantime,
once like a lab manager job.
And so they're exactly
the same job application,
the same cover letter
references, you know, grades,
everything's the same. And uh,
but once it's John on it at once,
it's Jennifer. That's the only
difference. And if you see the bar graph,
um, for the statistical
difference, it's so significant.
It's not like some little
sliver. It's huge, right?
That John was judged more hireable,
more competent,
and more worthy of being mentored.
Then Jennifer by huge margin and
if Jennifer was going to be hired,
her salary was a good four
to $5,000 lower than John's.
And we're talking really small salary.
So I mean, John would get like 30,
32 and she was going to get 28 or
it's 26 and 30, something like that.
So that's huge. Right? And what
really shocked me was that the,
the degree of bias did not
vary according to gender.
All right. So women who were
going to hire a lab manager, John,
just as much as guys who were going to
hire a lab manager and it didn't vary by
age, right? So if you were an
assistant professor or full professor,
you were 30 or you were 65,
you were just as biased against Jennifer,
except the Jennifer was much more
likely to be judged. Likable.
Like who did you think was more
likable? Jennifer. All right.
So what you could see how insidious
some of these things are cause shit.
People are Jennifer.
And you went in for the job interview.
You didn't come out thinking, Huh,
they really liked me. I got the job.
And you wouldn't even get why you didn't
get it because the people hiring you
wouldn't get why you didn't get it.
Okay.
So that I thought was shocking.
Um,
one study that's not in the book that
I'll share with you, that also shocked me.
So this one just came out literally
last week and it was done by actually a
friend of mine from the old days.
Um, Bob Saggy, who's in Boston.
They came out in the Journal of
American Medical Association.
So you tend to think too
that these problems aren't
as bad say in biology cause
those are now women's fields and
people fields or whatever. Um,
so this was in biomedical science and
the study measured startup grants for
first time hires. So if you, in
academia, you get your first layup,
you need money to set it up because you
haven't been able to get grants yet.
Right?
So the money comes from the institution
that hires you show the average for
women starting their lab,
their support money was $350,000,
which sounds like a lot,
right?
She could imagine a young
woman getting hired going, wow,
they hired me and they gave me
$350,000. Yes, thank you so much.
When do I start?
What was the average for guys?
Okay,
$890,000
as a half a million dollars
difference to start up your first lab.
Now imagine how that accumulates
in terms of your whole, right.
And nobody knows, right? The guys don't
know that the women are being screwed.
The women don't know, the guys are
getting 800. It clearly has to do with,
they don't know the reasons
cause this is a new study,
but you can imagine it might be
the people offering the money.
Don't even realize they're offering
more to the guy because he's a guy.
But then the guy knows to
bargain, to negotiate. Right.
Well I want even more than that. Whereas
the woman's getting lower and going,
thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Right.
So there's still much work to be done.
Um, the fourth part of the book is
sort of an epilogue in that, um,
after the piece came out in the times,
I just,
I got thousands of emails and
heard from all sorts of people,
mostly people who agreed about the
encouragement, the confidence factor in.
And I heard more so I focused
the book more on say physics,
but I heard a lot from people in tech
and finance and the issue seemed to be
very similar. Um, I heard
from women who would say,
I'd be in a room and I'd
get an idea, um, you know,
or I know how to solve the problem,
but I didn't have the confidence to just
say it right out and somebody else says
it first. And then I
kicked myself. So that,
that kind of thing in the implicit bias.
Um,
and then of course the
issues for childcare and, um,
how much of the house work you're
doing and all the, you know,
benefits for policies for I'm taking
time off if you're having a kid or,
or other family problems. So that's,
that's the final part of the book.
Um,
so again,
rather than read from the book and because
I'm hoping that maybe you'll take a
copy,
I thought I'd reach you a piece
that I just wrote the times, um,
wanted me to write an op Ed piece that
sort of is a, uh, a new angle on this.
And so this piece is,
um,
focus more on computer science and,
uh,
somebody else's research that just came
out. And I don't know that I'm right.
And so afterward,
I would love to hear your responses and
if it doesn't jive with your experience
or it doesn't sound
right, let me know. Okay.
The largest high tech
companies such as Google,
have finally begun to
devote serious resources to
attracting and promoting women
in minorities.
Unfortunately,
if young women and students of color
continue to shy away from classes in
computer science and engineering,
these firms will compete for the same
limited pool of employees who aren't white
or male.
Figuring out why people who choose not
to do something choose not to do it.
It's like trying to interview the
l to live inside your refrigerator,
but only come out when the light is off.
Women already working at a company
might tell you what makes them unhappy,
but these complaints won't necessarily
pinpoint the factors that frightened
girls away from studying computer
science in the first place.
As one of the few women
who's lived in both worlds,
I earned a bachelor of science and physics
from meal in 1978 but have lived the
past 35 years as a writer,
an English professor.
I've long been interested
in why women like me,
who loves science and math switched to
other fields and so many other women flee
in horror at the site of the simplest
equation that young women who love science
and math grow tired of being teased
about their interests seems easy to
understand. Rather than receive
encouragement, they face discouragement.
They may dislike working in a competitive
aggressive culture that demands they
give up any outside interests that
might keep them healthy and sane.
They face very real difficulties
trying to raise young children, walk,
carrying out research that might earn
them tenure when might strike people as
less plausible is that many young women
avoid studying computer science or
engineering simply because they fear they
won't fit in with the students who do
take such classes.
For the past six years,
SAP Cherian,
who's a psychology professor at
the University of Washington,
has been studying white girls in high
school are significantly less likely than
boys to sign up for class
in computer science,
take the AP exam in that subject or
express interest in computer science as a
career.
And why?
Female college students or four times
less likely than men to major in computer
science or engineering, even though
they test extremely well in math.
What Sherry is research reveals is that
many girls just don't think they would
feel comfortable in such a class.
This shouldn't be too surprising when
most of us are deciding whether to move to
a new town, join a club,
or take up a hobby.
We are as perceptive as Sherlock Holmes
and picking up clues as to whether we
might belong over and over.
Cherry and her colleagues have found that
female students are significantly more
interested in enrolling in a computer
class if they are shown a classroom,
whether virtual or real. So if it's for
an online class, right, the classroom,
you can make it look like anything.
Um,
it's decorated not with star wars posters,
science fiction books, computer parts,
tech magazines and boxes for
video games and software.
But rather with art and nature posters,
water bottles,
coffee makers, lamps, plants, pens
and general interest magazines.
So one is sort of this
stereotype of what you know,
computer science room is going to look
like in the other incident meant to be
feminine or masculine. It's
more neutral. Interestingly,
the willingness of most male students
tend to not to change significantly
whether they're shown a room decorated
in a stereotypical manner or a room with
a more neutral decor while about a quarter
of the women reported being drawn to
the more stereotypical setting. Okay. So
there's some women who are like, great,
I like Star Wars. Here I am. Um,
the importance of what Sharon calls an
ambient sense of belonging proves equally
strong with female college
students considering a job
in an office that does not
conform to their image of what a
computer company might look like.
Sherry and in her colleagues also found
that cultural stereotypes about computer
scientist strongly influenced
young women's desire to
take classes in the field.
At a young age.
Girls are ready hold stereotypes
of computer scientists
and we know this doesn't
apply to anybody.
We actually know as Pale,
awkward young men who
were socially isolated,
obsessively devoted to playing video
games and intensely focused on machinery
and whose genius is inborn rather than
the result of study and hard work.
Given that such stereotypes run
counter to the indoctrination,
most girls still receive that they
should be feminine, whatever that means.
Interested in working with other people
and modest about their abilities as well
as many girls beliefs that they are not
in neatly gifted at science or math.
It's no surprise that they cannot see
themselves as happy successful computer
scientists.
In another experiment Cherian and
her colleagues arrange for female
undergraduates to talk to an actor
pretending to be a computer science major.
If the actor wore a t shirt that said,
I code therefore I am and
claim to enjoy video games.
The female students express less interest
in studying computer science and less
confidence in succeeding in such a class.
Then if the actor war,
solid tee shirt and claim to
enjoy hanging out with friends,
even if the actor was another woman,
such stereotypes might seem laughably
outdated and yet studies show that the
basic stereotype of a scientist the most
people have hasn't changed since they
first started testing for it in the
1950s and these stereotypes do still have
some basis in reality.
In some ways,
young women today might have an even
harder time imagining themselves as
physicists,
engineers,
or computer scientists than when I was
a physics student in the mid seventies
back then,
women were still rebelling against the
norms of the 1950s most of us wouldn't
have been caught dead
pretending to be princesses,
even when we were little girls or
wearing high heels and fancy dresses.
As adults, we issued manicures,
makeup and hair salons,
fancy weddings.
The required a year of planning were
anathema and we weren't about to devote
every minute to hovering over our
children the way or stay at home.
Mothers hovered over us.
I'm not making a value judgment about
women should wear or shouldn't wear or how
much time they should or shouldn't devote
to their weddings so their families.
But young women today clearly face
more pressure to dress in a feminine,
sexy manner than they
did when I was young.
Which means that the gap between
the way women see themselves,
this most women and the
way they see scientists has
only grown wider in the past
few decades.
Not to mention that the messages young
women continue to receive from their
teachers, parents and classmates
convinced them this gap is real.
For instance,
one girl I know was recently told by
her high school teacher that she was too
pretty to be good at math and research
demonstrates that female undergraduates
who have watched commercials in which
women focus excessively on their
appearance demonstrate less interested
in careers in high tech than students who
haven't viewed such commercials.
Cherian and postulates is similar theory
to explain why the percentage of women
studying computer science has fallen
since the mid 1980s citing evidence that
high school students get their ideas
about scientists from popular culture in
the media.
She wonders if there might be a causal
link between the decline in women to
interest in computer science and the rise
of movies and TV shows such as revenge
of the nerds and the Big Bang theory
which portrays scientists and engineers is
white or Asian male geeks.
The media intense focus on the startup
culture and geniuses such as Steve Jobs
and Bill Gates might also have inspired
more young men than women tend to the
field. That's, that's her theory.
Even though very few jobs are located in
startup companies and very few computer
scientists,
Steve Jobs or Bill Gates,
again present company excluded some
people scarf that if young women are going
to let such nebulous factors deter them
from careers in physics or computer
science,
while the women are simply exercising
their own free choice and if girls were
tough enough,
such exaggerated stereotypes and feelings
of discomfort wouldn't discourage them.
Yet the stereotypes are still
pervasive. Just yesterday. Well,
yesterday from when I wrote this,
I was standing in line at my corner
pharmacy in New York when I realized that
the covers of the magazines I had been
staring at for 10 minutes showed a god
like portrait of Steve Jobs.
It was the subject of a recent
movie at the top beneath him,
a big busted model in her underwear.
Then a heroic,
clear eyed portrait of Mark Zuckerberg
and then at the very bottom,
another scantily clad female model.
All of us are bombarded by such images.
How can we not absorb the lesson
that computer geniuses, they're men.
While the chief goal of a woman's
life should be to look fabulous in her
underwear.
I wonder how many young men would choose
to major in computer science if they
suspect that they might need to carry
out their coding while sitting in a pink
cubicle decorated with posters of sex in
the city and film in Luis and copies of
vogue and cosmo scattered
around the lunchroom. In fact,
Sherry hands research shows that young
men tend not to matron English for the
same reasons. Most women don't
major in computer science.
They compare their notions of who they
are to their stereotypes of English
majors and decide they won't fit in.
All of this meshes with my own experience,
even though I felt more comfortable in
a tee shirt and jeans and address or a
stylish shoe. Sue, after four years
of majoring in physics at Yale,
I experienced so much pressure to dress
and act like a man that I began to feel
extremely uncomfortable about my identity
as a woman working as an intern at Oak
Ridge National Laboratory in Tennessee
or attending a conference on theoretical
physics in Austin,
Texas.
I felt out of place among my mostly
male colleagues because I hated drinking
beer or eating barbecue and didn't like
getting teased about reading novels.
I've heard similar stories
from countless women,
even the female students at Olin
College of engineering right here in
Massachusetts complaining to me about
feeling out of place among male classmates
who were always engaging in pissing
contests or burping the periodic table.
Those were their words or male coworkers
at summer jobs who continually cursed
and made vulgar jokes.
The good news is that women's stereotypes
of scientists can be surprisingly
malleable.
In one experiment,
young women who read a fake article
claiming that many computer scientists no
longer fit the geeky
stereotype demonstrated,
is significantly greater interested in
computer science than their counterparts
who read a fake article saying that the
stereotype remains true to make computer
science more attractive to women.
We might try to change how
women think about themselves,
but we might also diversify the images
of scientists the women see in the media,
along with the decor of classrooms in
which they might want to work to study
your work.
This would be especially easy to do in
the case of virtual classrooms for online
courses,
and the office is in which they all
they might apply to work in this way,
we could retain the men and women who
are drawn to the current images and
environment while attracting women and
men who might previously have shied away
because they felt they
wouldn't fit in after all.
High Tech Company isn't like the army
where the stereotype of a warrior is
inextricably linked to the actual
requirements of the job. Uh,
stylishly dressed woman in a cheerful
room with a beautiful painting on the wall
is just as likely to write a brilliant
line of code as a man in an I code.
Therefore I m t shirt sitting in a
dingy cubicle decorated with a star wars
poster and littered with
Soda Cans and pizza boxes.
Even small changes might
make a big difference.
A thoughtful male computer professor once
wrote me to suggest that changing the
name of the major from
computer engineering to
computer arts or computer arts
and sciences would double the
number of female students overnight.
Of course,
Lauren Young women into a field by
showing them images of offices that don't
exist and letting them read fake articles,
the complainant's claim
computer scientists or more
suave and socially adept
than they really are,
might be unfair.
But as Sherry and points
out this stereotypes or at
best only partially true,
and women who actually take classes in
computer science don't hold the same
negative views as women who get
their ideas from movies and TV shows.
Besides if companies do succeed in
attracting more women and minorities,
this stereotypes will change as well.
Presumably the grubby decor. Of course,
as I'm reading this to you,
I realize that this is the least grubby
decor that I have ever seen in my life.
So then that part clearly
doesn't apply to you guys.
This is why Mayor Bill de Blasio,
his recent announcement that within
10 years all of New York City's public
schools must offer at least some training
in computer science to all students is
so important as Cherian herself suggest
requiring all students to take computer
science.
Not only would change the stereotype
as to who does your doesn't take such
classes,
it would provide girls and students of
color with the opportunity to experience
the material and decide for themselves
if they like the work at the college
level.
Some fairly simple changes could allay
the anxieties of female and minority
students at Harvey Mudd College at college
strategies such as renaming courses.
So they took introduction to programming
in Java and renamed it creative
approaches to problem solving in
science and engineering using python.
Well, I don't know that
that, that's a direct,
but you can see the difference in the
kind of name it is creating separate
introductory class just for students
with zero programming experience and
students who already know how to
code discouraging show off behavior,
exposing students to non Geeky computer
scientists and allowing them to work on
projects that fit their preferences,
lead to an increase in the percentage of
computer science majors who were female
from 10 to 40% in only four years.
So just making these like
ridiculous kind of sounding changes.
They went from 10% of 40% female computer
science majors in four years as an
added benefit.
[inaudible] research on the effects of
stereotypes and what she calls an ambient
sense of belonging and career choices
might have important lessons to teach us
about how we might persuade more young
men to enter fields they traditionally
avoid such as nursing education,
early childcare and yes,
even English and creative writing. So, um,
so that's,
that's the piece I'm working on now and
I would just be happy to take questions
or hearing your disagreements,
your viewpoint.
You are the ones working in the
field. So, um, I would just love,
love to take questions or hear what
you think and if you have a question,
if you could go to one of the Mikes,
that would be great.
Yes.
Um,
so one thing I heard like as a refrain
throughout that is that if we hide away
geekiness thing,
we'll attract a more diverse culture.
And the problem with that is that like
geeks exist and many geeks in nerdy
people and weird people throughout
high school experience extreme Austria
Austria's is right for sure.
And um,
like kind of retreat
into hyper intelligent,
you know, kind of approaches. I think
I, I don't think this is an accident.
I don't think this is just an arbitrary
thing that happens for no reason at all.
Um,
those people feel very,
very invested in tech culture and they
feel that they are being attacked by the
bullies that bullied them in high school.
Right now we're all supposed to grow up
and become adults and realize it's more
complicated than that. I'm not
justifying their position. Right.
But I mean this is a very real
conflict, right? Totally metastasis.
I think it needs to be
addressed respectfully and
with, with an understanding.
So my question to you is to
answer those concerns. I think
what, what, what was, um,
in the piece that I read was
that we need to be open to more.
Okay. So we're not changing
or denigrating what is there.
We're opening to more possibilities.
Okay.
So what it was saying
is that there are uh,
people who, who were nerdy, Geeky,
whether by choice or that's just who they
are or they they want to do it. And um,
we want to keep those
people and respect them.
So it said 25% of the women who
were surveyed actually were drawn.
They, they were drawn to the classroom
that had the star wars posters. Okay.
And so I was very careful to say,
and Sheridan is very careful to say we
want to keep that right and respect those
people.
So it's not taking the people who were
bullying the Geeky kids or the women who
feel that they can't show their inner,
you know, math and science self.
Cause then they get bullied or teased
or nobody last them out, right?
It's trying to have both groups now
want to be free to take whatever kind of
court, not to be ruled by
stereotypes and bullying. All right?
So there's this anti intellectual culture
that affects young men and women who
are ha let their inner geek and nerd out.
Right?
And they get disrespected.
But then there are these girls who,
and probably some young men who
would like to be doing that, right?
But they're scared off because they've
been socialized by these images to say,
that's not me.
Or to fear that if they're like that no
one will like them or date them or you
know, be nice to them. We want
both of those groups. And,
and that was what I was kept trying to
say is that we want to make the images
more diverse to show more
possibilities so that anybody,
so we'll,
we'll draw in.
People will keep who we have now and
respect them and draw in people who are
being scared off by the
bullying and by saying,
but I'm different from um,
the kids who at least have each other
in the robotics club or the computer
science lab,
but I'm not like them.
And they think that's the only way to be.
So even though if you're in that room,
you feel like you're being
bullied or disrespected.
There's this other group
that's looking and saying,
at least you have an identity and
you're doing this thing where it's,
I don't fit in with you and I
don't fit in with them. Right.
So it's how do you get more,
first of all,
how do you get rid of the
awful stereotypes from the
movies and the TV shows
that are really not doing anybody
any good. And how do you say that?
There's room for many different kinds
of people that are currently in tech and
the way, so de Blasio saying everybody
has to take computer science.
At least you didn't get
everybody in the room.
And there's no more sense
of only those kids do it.
Or you'll be stigmatized if you do it.
And if you do it,
it's because you have to take the class
and then you discover you love it. Right.
So in a way to one way to literally get
everybody doing it and lessen the stigma
is to require everybody to do it.
The other way is to have more in it,
to be for all of us to be much
more alive to the stereotypes,
the images, the decor, and who,
who was being attracted by it and
who's being turned off by it and why.
And to realize that even though
it sounds like small stuff,
it's very powerful stuff. So yeah,
I totally agree with you and,
but there were lines,
there definitely were lines in here
that we're saying that we want to keep,
you know, and that there are women
and men that are attracted to this.
They're great. We want to keep
them, they should be happy,
but that there are other people that
they're actually being kept away by
thinking that's the only way
you have to be. Yeah. Hi.
Um,
Lord Mitson a two fuels I can think of
where there's been an increasing number
of women that uh, certainly
not equal yet, but much better.
And they both seem to be
Philly geeky fields in the
St math or computer sciences.
Have you,
do you have an opinion on whether we can
learn any lessons from those fields and
transfer them across
to sciences in general?
Which fields, um, are, are we, are you
talking about the law and Benson? Okay.
Yeah. Great. So yeah, I do. So
I'm especially in medicine. Um,
what happened in medicine
is really interesting. They,
the big stumbling block, there used
to be medical school training, right?
Um, well first of all there were
rules and women couldn't be doctors.
They wouldn't let him into med school.
But once they got past that,
there were women who wanted to be doctors,
but the training system was a grueling
hazing system where you had to be on call
for like four days straight and
you couldn't go home. And it,
it was incompatible with human
life. Right. And especially if you,
if there were children at
home, you couldn't just
disappear for four days. Right.
So only men who had a wife at home who
had stayed with the kids could do it,
but it wasn't even good for the men.
And it wasn't good for the
patients because a doctor
who's been up for four days
straight off and screw something up.
Um,
so long about the time my ex
husband was in medical school,
we met him through medical school,
but we made it through phd.
We didn't make it prepares much past that.
It was just because these
issues are so hard. Right?
So he was never home.
So there was a movement to change that.
And it was partly because women were
entering the field and it was keeping them
out.
And partly because the men were finally
admitting that it was destroying their
lives too.
So there was a move to humanize medical
school training so that you didn't have
to like give up your marriage, your
kids, your whole life to do it.
And that was a reason that more
women could go into the field.
They picked certain areas
that seem more girl friendly,
like being a pediatrician,
but you know,
it's spreading now even to some of
the heart, more hardcore specialties.
The reason that's relevant is because
I think phd training is still a hazing
like that.
It's still much more like medical school,
the old days where the idea is
if you're not sick, you know,
if you're not willing to be in the lab 24,
seven and give up every
other interest and you know,
forget about your spouse and any
responsibilities to any other human being,
you're not serious. You won't be
taken seriously and you don't belong.
And so we still lose a lot of women.
Um,
so it's just Grad school's
miserable for guys too,
but they tend to be more socialized to
tough it out. They have to have a career.
People don't let them just drop
out as quickly and easily. Um,
so that hazing,
um,
period in a profession tends to be a,
a block. And if you can
get rid of that. Um,
so I think in terms of fields that
where you need a phd, that that's the,
if you can do for the phd program,
which is humanize it,
the way medical school
training was humanized and
convince people it's not going
to lower standards that,
you know,
if you're trying to run a program or a
blog after you'd been up for four days,
you're going to screw it up the way
you would have killed your patient.
Now for tech,
I think it's more like what Anne Marie
slaughter was saying in her article,
which is just that if, if being in the
profession, like that article about,
I was at Amazon where you just have to,
like,
you're treated like crap and have to
work 900 hours a week and you know that
those, that idea of what is
needed to be good at your field,
I think is still something we, you know,
if that, if that applied to all fields,
if you can have things more humane,
right. And that's not the standard.
The other part of it is the stereotypes,
right?
So there's still this very
American idea that somehow girl,
you know, girl femininity does not
equate with math, computer tech,
right? These, the stereotypes that
girls who picked up by second grade.
And one thing I was really interested
to discover in researching this book is
that's not true in other
every other culture.
There are a lot of cultures where
women don't have certain other rights,
but it's inconceivable to
the men in those cultures.
The women wouldn't be as good at science,
math, computer programming, whatever,
coding, right? Which if you're American,
you go, wait, no, you know, we,
that's such a basic stereotype for us
and yet in other cultures is maybe the
woman needs her husband's permission to
go to a tech conference because they're
going to be other men there.
But he doesn't think,
but no one thinks there are cultures that
think women are better at math because
women are more creative than men. Right.
And that whole business about how,
you know, women used to be
the software people until,
because it was seen as just
the secretarial work until
the guys decided that was
the cool part.
And then they kicked him out.
So just these being alive to
sort of the hazing aspect,
the part that makes it in human,
but also the,
the way the stereotypes are just,
I think they're more pervasive today than
they were when I were young was young.
There's even more on women being
really traditionally girly,
feminine spending all their time, you
know, on planning weddings and stuff.
And that's just not,
and then they get a stereotyped idea of
what tech is like and the two just don't
Mesh.
So it's being really,
really alive to the stereotypes
that are so different. Yeah.
You were next.
So, um, I don't know if
you've seen, uh, there's a,
there's a woman online
who known as the key cast.
She was doing Linux colonel programming
and she's just decided that she's going
to step out because she's
done with the hazing. Um,
she's done with the combative attitude of,
of having to take a lot of crap,
which of course speaks to what you
were just saying, but what you're,
what you're addressing is what I think
we at Google tend to refer to as the
pipeline issue where
women aren't coming in,
but there's also a substantial issue
where a lot of women once they're in and
have been here for a while
will then drop out. Right.
I know that that's something that we've
seen with the numbers inside of Google.
Right. I don't know if I'm allowed to
actually say what those numbers are,
but certainly the higher
up the levels you go,
the fewer women there are.
Um,
do you have any ideas on how to address
the lack of role models as given that
there are a few women to
act as role models for women
who are joining the field?
It's much harder to then stick around
because you don't have a model on which to
base your,
what your
for. Sure. Um, well first
of all it's, you know,
I focused in the book much more on
sort of the pipeline issues because I,
my whole question was why didn't I go
on? Right. And if I had gone on and I,
you know,
spent 10 years working for a tech company,
I would have felt more secure focusing
on that. I should say that I did do pro,
you know,
I taught myself four Tran when I was
an Undergrad and did a program for a
professor of scattering program.
We didn't have, there were no pcs,
there were no screens.
So you had to do,
everything came out printed
on paper and you had a flip.
It was like a flip book to
make the simulation work.
And then I worked at Oak Ridge programming
a simulation there and you know,
I mean, so I have some sense of this, the
sexism there was just unbelievable. It,
I think that was the worst
I've ever experienced.
There were stuff called
job control language.
So you'd needed certain codes to even
get time on the computers and that it was
run by guys and mirrored sunglasses
who literally would make the women say,
say,
or do something sexy and suggestive so
that they could find out that they as JCL
language, you know, so I'm going to have
some idea of it, but it's not, I can't,
I feel like you guys are
the experts that said,
I've talked to a lot of
women and I think there's it.
What's really insidious instead,
it's so many relatively small,
uh, obstacles, insults, you know,
just the hardships that no one of
which is enough to make you just go,
that's it. That's the way a
straw. But they accumulate, right?
And in some ways,
so,
so a lot of what happens is somebody
finally can't take it and says,
I'm just going to stay
home and raise the kids,
or I'm going to do something different.
And then people say,
use that to justify that women are
no good or that they actually prefer
something else.
So the fact that I eventually became a
writer caused people to write to me and
say, we'll see you prefer to
people field. And I'm like, no,
it was made so miserable for me.
But it's gradual.
So the analogy I sometimes use is if you
were at the gym and you're on a tread
master and there's a guy on the next one,
right? And you both think that the, um,
inclined,
the resistance is the same,
but what you don't know is yours
to set higher, right? And she,
you're both going right and then you
speed it up and like you're sweating and
huffing and puffing and he's not so
much and you think what's wrong with me,
right? That it's harder for me.
And he's looking over and going,
why is she sweating and huffing and
puffing? We're both on the same treadmill.
And then you give each person one of
those balls at the gym that look the same,
but one is much heavier and you
don't know yours is heavier, right?
Cause I don't know this data that
you're not sharing, like right,
if everybody doesn't know the data,
that's childcare. That's parent care,
that's house care, right? And
at some point you're just like,
not only am I exhausted, but he's
not, so I must not be as good at this.
This isn't worth it.
I'll go,
just go take a yoga class and see women
look just like yoga classes, right? Show,
talking, right? Registering
what's going on.
So the more that you can be aware of
what's going into the fact that it seems
harder, like to articulate
that, to bring it out,
to make as much public as you can,
to be aware of it,
and to know what you're
at least experiencing and
fighting that he got $890,000
to set up his lab.
And I showed the women at Mit in the late
nineties to whom this first occurred.
Like, why are we so much
more tired than the guys?
Nobody wanted to share the data. They
forced the issue. Let's see, salaries,
they were on their hands and
knees measuring, um, lab space,
right? So whatever it is
that you can articulate, can,
I think that that's actually even more
important than literally having a role
model. Right? There were a lot
of guys who are very sympathetic.
I'm sure many of them are in this room,
right?
Having a sympathetic male supervisor or
a role model can be just as powerful.
And unfortunately sometimes it's so hard
for a woman to get to a certain point
that by the time she gets there, she
sort of like, I did it, I did it my way.
And it can be harder to have her as a
role model than a guy you because you
stuck out so much to defend.
Um,
so I sometimes hear from
women who disagree with
everything in my book and say
none of this is true because it didn't
apply to them. And I'm saying, right,
that's why you're the only woman
where you are and it's great.
I loved what you did.
But they are denying that their reality,
they're saying their realities
the same for everybody.
So it's also like not depending,
not taking your role model as
maybe the obvious choice. Right.
Sometimes my greatest
role model is as a writer,
it was an African American male
writer who was just brilliant and said
everything I needed to hear and he
was my role model, right? Worse.
There were some women writers,
older women writers who were,
I don't know where did,
they were trying to toughen me up or
they forgot that their age at my age,
they weren't so tough either or that
they needed encouragement when they were
young.
So sometimes you just have to
pick different role models or say,
oh, I can do it on my own because
I'm not on my own bit bit.
But with other women at the same level,
and some men bring in men, male allies,
just trying to articulate some of those
hidden stressors and differences and see
if you can work on those rather than
just let it all accumulate the way I did
and walk away from it.
Right.
And then be my age and
regret that you let people,
not that it's your weakness or your fault,
but if I had known what I was coping with,
I don't know that I would've walked
away. Okay. Here's another question.
We have time for it.
Yeah.
Hi. Um, so here I am. I made
it. I did finish my phd.
Uh, and um, I am just really fortunate.
I went to an all girl high school,
which set me up in college to not even,
I really did not notice that
I was in a room full of men.
I have a very funny story
that I will spare you. Um,
and then I was fortunate to find a female
professor who thought highly of me and
went out of her way to mentor,
not just me but other female scientist.
She was my phd advisor and I mean my,
my research group at my university,
we had parody because the two professors
in charge of our group went out of
their way. But I also have friends
who are software engineers,
women who are software engineers
at other companies and they,
they really do not have a good
time and these other companies.
So I was kind of scared. I said, Oh,
thank God I'm going to Google where they
have these things like unconscious bias
training and they care about this.
Um, so I guess the question is like,
if we are here and we made it, what
do we do to help? I'm not willing,
I mean I'm not going to go and be a
teaching high school cause that's not my
temperament, but what, what
can I realistically do to
help the women behind me?
All that's great. And I'm so,
and I have to say that, um,
although I don't have it as study,
I don't think studies have been done to
back this up after just six months doing
the research on that book.
I felt like I could tell if a woman had
gone to an all girl high school or if
I'm an African American student,
had gone to a historically black college
because there was something about that
experience of, especially if in junior
high and high school, um, you're,
you're saying that a
single sex institution,
it's almost like you get inoculated
against the stuff that really was so hard
for me. The, the encouragement,
lacking the confidence.
I don't know how it weighs out against
whether there are disadvantages of it,
but even later when women say
then they're in the room with men,
they just don't seem to experience the
same psychological, um, hindrances.
Um, and I think that's really important.
So with that Harvey Mudd College,
what they're doing now,
that first course separating people out
so that there's a room for it tends to
be mostly women, but some guys too
who have had no experience, right?
So they are not kind of intimidated away
by the mostly guys who feel really good
about their skills and are all too
ready to show, you know, so that,
that keeping things separate at least
long enough that people get their legs
under them I think is important.
So if you're working at the college level,
that's one way.
So you're not really separating by
gender accepted ends up being gender
influenced with the
experience. I think really, um,
the work to do is
trying to,
if there are things that work here,
trying to get other industries to adopt,
like what are the best practices? Can
you publish? Can you write op ed pieces?
I'm the one, they're asking the right,
the op Ed pieces. If you were writing it,
you'd know even more what to say.
Right.
And then people read it and
it spreads to other companies.
And to work on these
images, like, you know,
if you're watching a show or movie and
the imagery of who is or isn't a computer
scientist or what it's like to work
in the field, you know, you can exert,
get people to exert pressure on Facebook
or wherever on whoever made the movie
or selling the product. Um, so yeah,
I think there are are things to do,
um,
get support groups going,
go into other companies to be
a role model or a mentor. Um,
but yeah, I think that, um, the,
especially what you were talking about
with the single sex institutions,
it's very, um, it's very powerful.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
All right.
Uh,
so you talked a lot about how the
images of who computer scientists and
programmers are influences
people's perceptions,
but has there been any study about
what computer science is used for?
So sort of the popular conception
of Silicon Valley, you know,
disrupting industries and sort of,
it's tends to be very aggressive language.
And does that turn off people who just
don't see what programming could be used
for that sort of constructive
or creative or artistic?
Yeah, very much so. And, and Sharon works
on that and some other people have too.
So she, there two levels
of that to their, the,
the students who are just maybe thinking
of going into the field and taking up
first class are thinking about maybe
do I want to major in that then that is
extremely important. Like,
well what would I use this for?
And basically people have no
idea what you do with coding,
which seems, I know if you actually do
it, you know, it's everything you right.
But you don't get that if you don't
know what it is. Right. And so, um,
one of the things Harvey
Mudd lets students do is pick
their own projects, right?
So that would make it easy for you.
I mean, you're given some guidance,
but you can pick the thing that seems
important for you to work on. You know,
there's some notion that young women
want to work on people fields or things
that'll benefit humanity.
I,
I've never really seen a study that
proves that to my satisfaction.
And I always wonder where
that notion comes from.
I think it gets drummed into your head
if you're a girl that you should want to
work on.
Some people feel that's good for humanity
because I remember people saying it to
me,
like I'd say I want to be a physicist.
And I remember my social
studies teacher saying, no,
you should want to work on a people field.
So like,
where does it really come from?
Um,
but that's a lot of the work that's
being done with like girls coding clubs,
robotics, clubs like that. A lot
of work is actually being done.
It's never enough,
but they're trying to work with like
seventh and eighth grade girls in clubs.
Like what would you use coding for?
And this is something that's enjoyable
to you and it's not like to blow people's
heads up or, you know, on a
video game or something. Um,
and then there's the level at which once
you're in start to be in the culture,
the aggression and the competitiveness.
That's more the hazing stuff that I
was talking about before the culture.
And again,
a big part of what I'm trying to do,
especially in physics,
but it's the exact same thing here is
changed that culture because I just don't
think it's healthy for anybody.
And I think there are a lot of guys who
don't like it and get caught up in it
because it's the way they
think they have to be. Um,
the other woman,
so I was one of two women who graduate.
We were the first graduates
with a physics degree.
The other woman became
just a whiz programmer.
I mean she's just brilliant and she's,
well she started at bell labs,
worked at all these other places
and she's been kind of edged out.
She's currently unemployed
and she's utterly brilliant.
But the competitive, sexist, ageist stuff,
just,
she got edged out.
So it's working on that culture.
When you see it calling it like,
why did you have to talk
to the person that way?
Or like if somebody presents something,
do you have to jump on them first?
Could you maybe say like what was good
about what they did before you make
suggestions? That's,
that's the difference. Um,
one last thing is, um,
one thing that struck me,
so was trying to recruit more minority
employees and they had one African
American engineer was
pretty high up and he went,
I don't know if it was his alma mater,
he just decided to go to,
I think it was Howard University.
And he said,
how many of you would be,
how many of you use Dropbox?
And like a lot of them raise your hands
because like we, a lot of us use Dropbox.
You said,
Whoa,
once you like to come work for the
company that makes this happen.
And they're like, yeah, we really
would. Would you like us to come?
Nobody's ever recruited anybody
here and we'd love to do this.
Part of it was they didn't
know, Oh yeah, I use this thing.
It would be fun to create stuff like this.
So that's part of it.
Knowing what,
what you do with it,
but also thinking you're wanted
because you look at the, you know,
the room or the movie or the whatever,
and there's nobody who looks like you
there and nobody's coming to your school
to recruit. So yeah, all of the above.
What do you had to do with this?
And I think what happens is
once you're in the field,
it's so obvious to you that to get that
back down to the level of like an eighth
grade girl or an eighth grade
boy, or who are, you know,
or an African American kid, you
know, why is it not obvious to them?
Where was it that you picked up the ideas
and how are these people either being
welcomed or scared away? Um,
that's, that's sort of where it,
where it is.
Okay.
I think that I'm being signaled
that we have our time up, so I will,
I will stick around as long as you'd
like me to see if anybody wants the book.
But thanks so much for inviting me.
I really am glad I got to meet you guys.